factor T squared + 8 t + 15 so let's
just think about what happens if we
multiply two binomials t plus a times T
plus B and I'm using T here because T is
the variable in the polynomial that we
need to factor so if you multiply this
out applying the distributive property
twice or using foil you get T times T
which is T squared plus T times B which
is BT plus a times T which is a T plus a
times B which is a B we essentially
multiplied every term here by every term
over there and then we have two terms
two t terms I guess you could call them
this is BT plus a T so we could combine
those and we get T squared plus a plus
BT I could've written this is B plus a T
as well plus a B now if we compare this
to this right over here we see that we
have a similar pattern our coefficient
our coefficient on the second degree
term is 1 our coefficient on the second
degree term here is 1 we didn't have to
write it then a plus B is the
coefficient on T so 8 right over here
this 8 could be a plus B and then
finally our constant term a B that could
be 15 that could be 15 so if we wanted
to factor this out we just have to find
an A and a B where their product is 15
and their sum is 8 in general in general
if you ever see and I'll write it in
kind of the more traditional with an X
variable if you see anything of the form
x squared plus BX plus C the coefficient
here is 1 then you just have to find two
term or two numbers whose sum is equal
to this thing right here and whose
product is equal to that thing right
there whose sum is equal to 8 and whose
product is equal to 15 so what are two
numbers that add up to eight whose
products are 15 so if you just factor
fifteen it could be 1 and 15 those don't
add up to 8 in any way 3 & 5 those do
add up to 8 so a and B could be 3 & 5 so
a and B this could be 3 times 5 and then
8 is
three plus five now we could just go
straight and factor this and say hey
this is T plus three times T plus five
since we already figured out what a and
B are but what I want to do is is kind
of factor this by grouping so I'm
essentially going to go in reverse steps
from what I just showed you so this
first this polynomial right here I'm
going to write it as T squared plus
instead of writing eight T I'm gonna
write it as the sum of a T plus B T or
as a sum of three T plus 5 T so plus 3t
plus 5 T so I'm essentially I've started
here and then I'm going to this step
where I break up that middle term into
into with the coefficients that add up
to the eight and then finally plus 15
and now I can factor it by grouping
these two guys right over here have a
common factor T and then these two guys
over here have a common factor 5 so
let's factor out the T in this first
expression right over here or this part
of the expression so it's T times T plus
3 plus and then over here if you factor
out a 5 you get a 5 times t plus 3 5t
divided by 5 is T 15 divided by 5 is 3
and now you can factor out a T plus 3
you have a T plus 3 being multiplied
times both of these terms so let's
factor let's factor that out so it
becomes T plus 3 times times T plus 5
times let me write that plus a little
bit neater times T plus 5 and we are
done but we actually didn't even have to
do this grouping step although hopefully
you see that it does work we could have
just said look from this pattern over
here I have two numbers that add up to 8
and their product is 15 so this must be
T plus 3 times T plus 5 or T plus 5
times T plus 3 either way